this week we're talking about data
discovery planning for your cloud
migration and more ways to use
kubernetes I'm Joanna Smith and welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news cloud data
catalog is now available in public beta
data catalog is a fully managed data
discovery and metadata management
service which means you can use data
catalog to easily search for tables in
Google bigquery or topics in cloud
pub/sub you can even filter for
sensitive data
thanks to data catalogs integration with
cloud data loss prevention get searching
and see for yourself
migration to the cloud unlocks some
awesome benefits but wrapping your head
around the journey there can be daunting
to help you think there the most
important question so we've gotten all
in one planning resource from assessing
what to move and why to provisioning and
configuring the new architecture you
settle on no question is too small for
this guide find a quiet nook and get
started connecting to external services
on kubernetes has historically required
compromises but no more thanks to a
workload identity workload identity
creates a relationship between
kubernetes service accounts and cloud I
am so that ye you can define which
workloads run us which identities grant
access to other cloud services and never
worry about kubernetes secrets or i''m
service account keys again try it on GCP
today running a database in a
distributed environment can be
challenging but if inherent benefits
like rapid spin up and repeatability
keep calling your name this blog is for
you in it we'll explore what types of
databases can be effectively run on
kubernetes when it makes the most sense
and why make an informed decision about
where to run your databases with this
fast read on the GCP blog now if you
want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link have any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us and we'll
see you in the cloud
you